This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Millions of us try to lose weight every year. We go on diets, read books, buy pills off the internet. Collectively, we spend billions of dollars trying to slim down. And the truth is, we might as well flush a lot of that money down the toilet. All those workouts, challenges and temptations. toilet. As they say in the infomercials, there must be a better way. This week, we're going to talk about psychological tricks we can play on ourselves to help us eat better and to follow through on our best intentions. My name is Adam Brumberg. I am the Deputy Director of the Cornell Food and Brand Lab at Cornell University.
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们每年都有数以百万计的人尝试减肥。我们节食、读书、从网上买药。我们总共花了数十亿美元来试图瘦下来。但事实是，我们把其中许多钱直接扔进马桶里也没什么两样。所有这些锻炼、挑战和诱惑。马桶。正如电视购物广告里所说，一定有更好的办法。本周，我们将讨论我们可以对自己使用的心理小把戏，来帮助我们吃得更好，并坚定我们最好的意愿。我叫亚当·布伦贝格。我是康奈尔大学康奈尔食品与品牌实验室的副主任。
Adam Brumberg and his colleagues research food psychology and they find that many of our food choices aren't really conscious choices. The majority of your food decisions are based on habit or convenience. You know, habit being, I did it yesterday, worked out fine. I'm going to do it again and convenience. Well, I'm sitting at my desk and there is a package of ring things on the desk and so I'm just going to eat that and instead of going to find something that's healthier. Once you understand these bad unconscious patterns, you could stay on guard, use willpower to fight them. But this also a smarter way.
亚当·布伦贝格和他的同事们研究食品心理学，他们发现我们的许多食物选择其实并非有意识的选择。你绝大多数的食物决定都是基于习惯或便利。你知道的，习惯就是，我昨天这么做了，结果很好。我还要再做一次，而便利呢。好吧，我正坐在办公桌前，桌上有一包圈状零食，所以我打算就吃那个，而不是去找更健康的东西。一旦你了解了这些糟糕的无意识模式，你就可以保持警惕，用意志力去对抗它们。但这也有一个更聪明的方法。
You could turn the tables and get these unconscious habits to work for you. Yeah, I mean, we like to say that the best diet is the one you don't know you're on. Our research shows you make about 200 food related decisions a day, which is a lot. By food decisions, Adam doesn't just mean whether you eat a salad or a sandwich. It's also, how much salt do you put on your food?
你可以扭转局势，让这些无意识的习惯为你所用。是的，我的意思是，我们喜欢说最好的饮食法就是那种你意识不到自己在进行的饮食法。我们的研究表明，你一天大约要做200个与食物相关的决定，这非常多。所谓的食物决定，亚当指的不只是你吃沙拉还是三明治。还包括，你在食物里放了多少盐？
Do you have a slice of cake when your coworker celebrates a birthday? Do you reward yourself for going to the gym with a cookie? Here's one example of how you can turn the tables on your unconscious habits. Adam and his colleagues find that volunteers and lab experiments make worse choices when they're stressed. The stress out folks were more likely to buy a dessert or to select a fried item as opposed to the people asked to think of things they were grateful for, they were more likely to get salad or grilled chicken or whatever it was.
当同事庆祝生日时，你会吃一块蛋糕吗？你是否会用一块曲奇来犒劳自己去健身房？这里有一个例子，说明如何扭转你对无意识习惯的局面。亚当和他的同事发现，实验室实验中的志愿者在压力下会做出更糟糕的选择。感到压力的人更有可能购买甜点或选择油炸食品，而那些被要求回想自己感激的事情的人，更有可能选择沙拉、烤鸡或其他健康的食物。
Once you understand how stress shapes mindless eating, you can set up a system when you're not stressed that allows you to take advantage of this tendency. If you pack a lunch the night before, you're definitely gonna put together something that's a lot more helpful than if you are, you know, doing as you're running out of the house in the morning.
一旦你了解了压力是如何塑造无意识进食的，你就可以在没有压力的时候建立一个系统，让你能够利用这种倾向。如果你在前一天晚上打包午餐，你做出的搭配绝对比你早上急急忙忙出门时随手弄的要健康得多。
Now Adam Brumberg says, when you're stressed out at work and mindlessly reaching for something to eat, your hands gonna come up with a carrot, rather than a ring. You have to work really hard to eat too many baby carrots. We decided to devote this whole episode to ideas like this. Coming up in a moment, senior stop-what science correspondent Dan Pink and I are going to create psychological tricks that might help your actual waistline look like the one you want.
现在亚当·布伦贝格说，当你在工作中感到压力山大并且下意识地伸手去抓食物时，你的手拿出来的会是一根胡萝卜，而不是一个圈状零食。你需要付出很大的努力才会吃掉太多的胡萝卜小方块。我们决定把整集节目献给这样的想法。稍后，高级“别管我”科学记者丹·平克和我将创造一些心理小把戏，可能帮助你的真实腰围看起来像你想要的那样。
Behavioral science has given us lots of tricks for eating less, smaller plates, smaller portions, but a new study this year in the Journal of the Association of Consumer Research offers another option, larger tables. So pull up a chair at a big table and stay with us. Support for Hidden Brain and the following message comes from Wells Fargo. Wells Fargo understands that you work hard to get the most out of life. From starting a business to saving for retirement, there are a lot of things you want to accomplish. Working together Wells Fargo will take the time to understand what you're trying to achieve, to help you reach your financial goals.
行为科学为我们提供了许多少吃的诀窍，比如更小的盘子、更小的分量，但今年《消费者研究杂志》上的一项新研究提供了另一种选择：更大的桌子。所以，在一张大桌子旁拉一把椅子坐下来，和我们继续收听。对《隐秘的大脑》的支持以及以下信息来自富国银行。富国银行理解你为充分体验生活所做出的努力。从创业到为退休储蓄，你有很多想要实现的目标。通过共同合作，富国银行将花时间理解你努力实现的目标，以帮助你达成财务目标。
That way you can care for the people and things that matter most. Learn more at WellsFargo.com slash together. Wells Fargo, together we'll go far. Support also comes from Atlassian. Today nearly anything is possible, and if we can dream it, teams can build it. So how do you bring everyone together to realize their shared vision? With Atlassian, makers of software for teams. Jira, Confluence, HipChat, and BitBucket
这样你就可以照顾到最重要的人和事。了解更多请访问 WellsFargo.com slash together。富国银行，携手走得更远。支持还来自 Atlassian。今天几乎任何事情都是可能的，如果我们能梦想，团队就能构建它。那么，如何将所有人聚集在一起以实现他们的共同愿景呢？通过 Atlassian，团队软件的制造商。Jira、Confluence、HipChat 和 BitBucket
give your team everything you need to organize, discuss, and complete shared work. Atlassian works to help teams large and small ascend to new heights to create what's next. Visit Atlassian.com. Atlassian works to help teams large and small ascend to new heights to create what's next. Visit Atlassian.com. Atlassian, team up. If you love listening to Hidden Brain, you're going to want to check out the new CodeSwitch podcast. Hosted by Jean Demby and Shereen Marisol Moraggi, CodeSwitch is a podcast that helps us understand
为你的团队提供组织、讨论和完成共同工作所需的一切。Atlassian 致力于帮助大小团队攀登新高度，创造未来。访问 Atlassian.com。Atlassian 致力于帮助大小团队攀登新高度，创造未来。访问 Atlassian.com。Atlassian，团队协作。如果你喜欢听《隐秘的大脑》，你一定会想去看看全新的 CodeSwitch 播客。由简·登比和谢琳·玛丽索尔·莫拉吉主持，CodeSwitch 是一个帮助我们理解
how race and identity shape our lives. This week, they tackle the subject of whiteness. What does it mean? And why is it important that we figure out how to talk about it? Find code switch on the NPR1 app and at npr.org slash podcast. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaantha. Samar is around the corner which means beaches and swimsuits are around the corner, too. Today, with the view of getting myself into beach-ready shape, I've asked Daniel Ping to come in to trade psychological tricks on how to eat better.
种族和身份如何塑造我们的生活的播客。本周，他们探讨了白人属性的主题。这意味着什么？为什么弄清楚如何谈论它如此重要？在 NPR1 应用和 npr.org slash podcast 上寻找 code switch。这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。夏天即将来临，这意味着海滩和泳衣也近在眼前。今天，为了让我自己达到海滩准备就绪的身材，我请来丹尼尔·平克交流关于如何吃得更好的心理小把戏。
We're also going to look at some surprising factors that make us eat worse. Dan, of course, is our senior stop-what science correspondent, or actually, I should say, our svelte senior stop what science correspondent welcome Dan thank you chunker now I would say my body is beach ready on the radio what about yours Dan uh you know what I don't really think in those terms I tend to go out in public uh fully if not heavily closed all right now as you know on stop what science Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to
我们还将探讨一些让我们吃得更糟的惊人因素。丹当然是我们的高级“别管我”科学记者，或者实际上，我应该说是我们苗条的高级“别管我”科学记者，欢迎丹，谢谢尚卡尔。现在我要说，我的身材在收音机里已经为海滩做好准备了，你呢，丹？呃，你知道吗，我其实不按那种方式思考，我往往会完全地，如果不是全副武装的话，穿着衣服出门。好吧，现在正如你在“别管我”科学中所知，丹和我给彼此60秒时间来
summarize interesting social science research. As we approach the 60 second mark, our producers will bring up the music just like they do with the Oscars. Dan and I will each present three different pieces of social science research. We'll also spend a little more time between the segments unpacking the science and its implications. Our topic today is dieting and the many ways in which hidden and unconscious factors shape our diets.
总结有趣的社会科学研究。当我们接近60秒大关时，我们的制作人会像在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上那样播放音乐。丹和我将各自介绍三项不同的社会科学研究。我们还将在各个环节之间花更多时间来剖析科学及其意义。我们今天的主题是节食，以及隐藏和无意识因素塑造我们饮食的种种方式。
Dan, if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Behavioral science has given us lots of tricks for eating less. Smaller plates, smaller portions, but a new study this year in the Journal of the Association of Consumer Research offers another option, larger tables. What? Yes, for these experiments, researchers got a bunch of pizzas and a bunch more college students. They found that students consumed the least amount of pizza
丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。行为科学为我们提供了许多少吃的诀窍。更小的盘子，更小的分量，但今年《消费者研究杂志》上的一项新研究提供了另一种选择，更大的桌子。什么？是的，为了这些实验，研究人员找来了一堆披萨和更多的大学生。他们发现学生们消费的披萨最少
when they were served small slices on a large table. Sounds weird, but there's a good explanation. When students saw the small slices on a tiny table, they quickly noticed just how measly those slices were. So, of course, they grabbed more. But when those same small slices were on a big table, their attention shifted away from the smallness of the pizza slices and toward the largeness of the table.
当他们在长桌上享用小切块时。听起来很奇怪，但有一个很好的解释。当学生们看到小桌子上的小切块时，他们很快注意到这些切块是多么微不足道。所以，当然，他们抓了更多。但当同样的小切块摆在一张大桌子上时，他们的注意力从披萨切块的小转移到了桌子的大。
On a large table, the small slices seemed not so measly after all. So students didn't feel the need to pile as many on their plate and ended up consuming less pizza overall. The lesson here? Large tables may prevent large people. Alright Dan, I have a question. Yes. Are the researchers saying that the fact that we see these pizza slices differently on small tables versus large tables, are they saying this is because of an optical illusion?
在一张大桌子上，小切块看起来似乎并没有那么微不足道。所以学生们觉得没必要在盘子里堆那么多，最终总体上吃的披萨变少了。这里的教训是什么？大桌子也许能防止胖身材。好吧，丹，我有个问题。是的。研究人员是否在说，我们在小桌子和大桌子上对这些披萨切块的看法不同，是因为一种光学错觉？
A little bit of an optical illusion. The way our vision works is that we don't see things in absolute terms, we see them in relative terms. So when you have small slices on a tiny table, you can actually see how small those slices are. But on a big table, everything looks about the same size because there's greater contrast. Therefore, people on the big table, everything looks about the same size because there's greater contrast. Therefore, people on the big table will eat the small slices,
有一点光学错觉。我们视觉的工作方式是，我们不是以绝对值来看待事物，我们是以相对值来看待它们的。所以当你在一个小桌子上有小切块时，你实际上能看到这些切块有多小。但在大桌子上，由于有更大的对比度，一切看起来都差不多大。因此，在大桌子的人，一切看起来都差不多大，因为有更大的对比度。因此，在大桌子上的人会吃小切块，
they'll eat fewer of them, and consume less pizza in total. That makes sense. So, Shunker, you and I are sitting here at a large table ourselves. So, why don't you give us a small idea? I'm gonna give you a small portion of an idea, Dan. It's gonna slice. It's gonna fit in 60 seconds. It turns out it isn't just the size of your dining table
他们会少吃一些，总共吃掉的披萨也更少。这说得通。所以，尚卡尔，你和我自己正坐在一张大桌子旁。那么，你为什么不给我们一个小想法呢？我要给你一个想法的一小部分，丹。它会被切片。它会在60秒内搞定。事实证明，不只是你的餐桌大小
that influences how much you eat. Your dining companions might make a difference, too. I did a story about this for NPR some time ago. Molly Allen O'Donnell told me that when she was a graduate student at Indiana University of Pennsylvania, she sat down in a college cafeteria and looked at how much food people bought for lunch and dinner. She noticed that when women sat with other women, they ordered an average 833 calories of food.
会影响你吃多少。你的共进晚餐的同伴也可能会产生影响。不久前我为 NPR 做过一个关于这方面的报道。莫莉·艾伦·奥唐纳告诉我，当她在宾夕法尼亚印第安纳大学读研究生时，她坐在大学食堂里，观察人们午餐和晚餐买多少食物。她注意到当女性和其他女性坐在一起时，她们平均点833卡路里的食物。
When they sat with men, they ordered only 721 calories. So women ate more when they ate with women and they ate less when they ate with men. Now, what about men? I hear you asking the question, Dan. What about men? When men sat with other men, they ordered 952 calories, but when they sat with women, they ordered 1,100 and 62 calories. So another way to put this is, both men and women ate more when they ate with women, and both men and women ate less when they ate with men. Now, I'm sure we're going to talk about why this might be the case, Dan. But I want to take a moment to shout out to every overweight married heterosexual man who
当她们和男性坐在一起时，她们只点了721卡路里。所以女性和女性一起吃时吃得更多，而和男性一起吃时吃得更少。那么，男性呢？我听到你在问这个问题，丹。男性怎么样？当男性和其他男性坐在一起时，他们点了952卡路里，但当他们和女性坐在一起时，他们点了1162卡路里。所以换句话说，无论是男性还是女性，和女性一起吃时都吃得更多，而无论是男性还是女性，和男性一起吃时都吃得更少。现在，我确信我们要讨论这背后的原因，丹。但我想花点时间向每一个超重的已婚异性恋男性致敬，
is listening. The next time your wife tells you to lose a few pounds, you might want to say, honey, it's your fault. Oh nice. Nice. You know, I think it's interesting. The takeaway for me is that if you want to lose weight, eat with men. I think that is why. But why would is why do men eat so much around women?
正在听节目的你们。下次你妻子叫你减掉几斤时，你可能会想说，亲爱的，这是你的错。哦，不错。不错。你知道，我认为这很有趣。对我的启发是，如果你想减肥，就和男人一起吃。我认为这就是原因。但是为什么男人在女人周围会吃那么多呢？
I don't think the study conclusively answers that question then. There was a related study that I saw by Kevin Niffin at Cornell University. He and his colleagues found that men eat 93% more pizza and 86% more salad when eating with a woman compared to eating with a man. So it isn't just eating more unhealthy food, it's just eating more food in general. Now, other studies have shown that heterosexual men in general tend to pursue more risky behaviors in the presence of women. Studies show that mixed sex groups, for example, make more risky financial decisions.
我认为这项研究并没有确切地回答那个问题，丹。我看到了康奈尔大学的凯文·尼芬的一项相关研究。他和他的同事发现，与和男人一起吃饭相比，男人在和女人一起吃饭时会多吃93%的披萨和86%的沙拉。所以这不仅是吃更多不健康的食物，而只是总体上吃更多的食物。现在，其他研究表明，异性恋男性在女性面前总体上倾向于追求更多冒险行为。研究表明，例如，男女混合群体会做出更多冒险的财务决定。
So it's possible that men are acting out some kind of evolutionary script by eating more food and Demonstrating they're capable of risk-earned behaviors. So they lose their inhibitions They show I'm a big risk taker who can go out there and slay that saber-tooth Tiger Exactly. So for my experience back many many years ago I would just be so psyched that a woman would be willing to eat with me that probably lose my Innovations start gorging on pizza. You know, maybe that men who are able to eat a lot of food may have signaled some kind of evolutionary fitness in our ancient past.
所以这可能是男人在演绎某种进化剧本，通过吃更多的食物并展示他们有能力进行冒险行为。所以他们卸下防备，展现出“我是一个敢于出去斩杀那头剑齿虎的伟大冒险家”的面貌。完全正确。所以根据我很多很多年前的经历，我会超级兴奋，竟然有女性愿意跟我一起吃饭，以至于我可能会卸下心防，开始狂吞披萨。你知道，也许能够吃大量食物的男性在我们的远古过去可能标志着某种进化适应性。
Now of course, when food is so plentiful today, it might signal something else altogether. A lack of fitness. All right, let's see if you can signal to me that you can stick your time, Dan. Your next 60 seconds starts right now. You are what you eat. We've all heard that. But this next study shows you are also when you eat. Researchers at Tel Aviv University's Medical School randomly assign 93 overweight women
当然，当今食物如此充足时，它可能完全标志着别的东西。缺乏适应性。好吧，让我们看看你是否能向我表明你能坚守时间，丹。你的下一个60秒现在开始。人如其食。我们都听过这个。但接下来的这项研究表明，你什么时候吃也很重要。特拉维夫大学医学院的研究人员随机将93名超重女性
into two groups. Both groups ate the same food. 1400 calories a day, not very much, for 12 weeks. But one group consumed half the calories at breakfast. But one group consumed half the calories at breakfast. The other group consumed half the calories at dinner. When the study was over, the big dinner group had lost an average of about 7 pounds, not that. But the big breakfast group, those who ate the same food, just earlier in the day, lost
分为两组。两组吃相同的食物。每天1400卡路里，不是很多，持续12周。但其中一组在早餐时消耗了一半的热量。但其中一组在早餐时消耗了一半的热量。另一组在晚餐时消耗了一半热量。研究结束时，丰盛晚餐组平均减重大约7磅，不算那个。但是丰盛早餐组，那些吃相同食物，只是吃得更早的人，减掉的重量
more than double that, an average of more than 17 pounds. They also reduced their waistline more than the dinner group, and even had greater drops in glucose, insulin, and triglycerides, high levels of which can lead to metabolic problems. Again, same food, same calories, just a different schedule. The bottom line, in eating as in life, timing is everything. So what I find interesting about the study done is that it contradicts a view that I think many people hold, which is that dieting is all just about calories in, calories out. Because what the study is suggesting is that it's not just about calories in, calories out,
超过了两倍多，平均超过17磅。他们的腰围缩减也比晚餐组更多，甚至在葡萄糖、胰岛素和甘油三酯方面的下降幅度也更大，这些物质水平过高会导致代谢问题。再说一次，同样的食物，相同的卡路里，只是不同的时间表。一句话，在饮食中和生活中一样，时机就是一切。所以我发现关于这项研究有趣的地方在于，它反驳了我认为许多人持有的观点，即节食完全就是进出的卡路里。因为这项研究表明，这不仅仅是进出的卡路里，
it's when you eat those calories that can make a huge difference. Yeah, yeah, our bodies are very, very complex systems. They, they don't work like simple machines. They're much more complex than that. And a lot of, uh, endocrinologists, a lot of physicians are trying to figure out exactly what that right mix is, but it turns out that the questions of when can be just as important as questions of what. Now, here's a what question for you. What do you got on your plate for your next study? Alright, this next study will be of interest to anyone who hangs around with small kids.
你什么时候摄入这些卡路里会产生巨大的差异。对，对，我们的身体是非常非常复杂的系统。它们不像是简单的机器那样工作。它们比那复杂得多。许多内分泌学家、许多医生都在试图弄清楚究竟什么是正确的组合，但事实证明，什么时候吃的问题可以和吃什么的问题同样重要。现在，这里有一个关于吃什么的问题。在你的下一项研究中，你有什么好料？好吧，接下来的这项研究将引起任何与小孩子打交道的人的兴趣。
What's one way you get youngsters to eat healthy food? You educate them about the health benefits of the food. But is this actually a good idea? New social science research suggests maybe not. Miha Maymarin at Northwestern, anle at Fishbuck at the University of Chicago, find that children who are told that crackers are healthy infer that this means the crackers are not yummy and they eat less of them. The researchers tried another experiment with carrots. They told preschoolers that eating carrots would help them become better readers.
让年轻人吃健康食物的方法之一是什么？你向他们普及食物对健康的益处。但这真的是个好主意吗？新的社会科学研究表明可能并非如此。西北大学的米哈·梅马林和芝加哥大学的安·菲什巴克发现，被告知苏打饼干很健康的儿童会推断这意味着苏打饼干不好吃，他们吃的就更少了。研究人员用胡萝卜进行了另一项实验。他们告诉学龄前儿童，吃胡萝卜能让他们成为更好的阅读者。
Again, they find that creating this kind of instrumental goal causes the preschoolers to eat fewer carrots. Basically the researchers think that when preschoolers are given one kind of association, crackers are healthy or carrots help you with reading, they unconsciously infer that alternate associations must be weaker, the carrots and the crackers can't be tasty. The moral of the story is, if you want kids to eat certain kinds of food, sell the tastiness of the food rather than the health benefits. Wow, so sell the steak, not the sizzle.
同样，他们发现创造这种工具性目标会导致学龄前儿童吃更少的胡萝卜。基本上，研究人员认为，当学龄前儿童被赋予一种关联时，比如饼干是健康的或胡萝卜有助于阅读，他们会无意识地推断出其他关联肯定较弱，胡萝卜和饼干一定不好吃。这个故事的寓意是，如果你想让孩子们吃某种食物，多推销食物的美味，而不是健康的益处。哇，所以要卖牛排，不要卖滋滋声。
Exactly. Yeah, I also think another factor that could be at work here is that any child who hears an adult say that carrots will make you a better reader knows that is not an adult they could ever trust. In other words, kids are just good lie detectors. Yeah, exactly. Kids are good lie detectors, no matter what they eat. But it is interesting because we do, I mean, I remember when my kids were growing up, you
完全正确。是的，我还认为这里可能起作用的另一个因素是，任何听到成年人说胡萝卜会让你成为更好读者的孩子，都知道那绝不是一个他们可以信任的成年人。换句话说，孩子们就是优秀的测谎仪。是的，完全正确。无论他们吃什么，孩子们都是出色的测谎仪。但这很有趣，因为我们确实，我的意思是，我记得我的孩子长大的时候，你
do want them to eat healthy, and so you're not sure how to persuade them to do it. And so basically what you're saying is they push the good taste rather than the ancillary benefits. Yeah, and I think when we think about many things in human behavior, Dan, I think we often assume that presenting the rational arguments to people is the best way to go. And so if you're selling carrots, you sell the rational arguments that carrots are good for you. The rational arguments don't always work and sometimes they backfile. Yeah, especially when it comes to eating. All right, let's see if this rational argument has any benefits.
确实希望他们吃得健康，所以你不太确定如何说服他们做到这一点。所以你基本上是在说他们主推好味道而不是附加的好处。是的，我想当我们思考人类行为中的许多事情时，丹，我们常常假设向人们提出理性论点是最好的方法。所以如果你在卖胡萝卜，你会推销理性的论点，即胡萝卜对你有好处。理性的论点并不总是奏效，有时它们会适得其反。是的，特别是在饮食方面。好吧，让我们看看这个理性论点是否有任何好处。
Dan, if you're going to be done on time, you have to do your next segment on time and your next 60-second starts right now. Well, as we've discussed, all kinds of hidden forces affect how much we eat. But here's one I didn't expect. The weight of your waiter or waitress. Oh, boy.
丹，如果你要按时完成，你必须按时完成你的下一个环节，你的下一个60秒现在开始。正如我们所讨论的，各种隐藏的力量影响着我们吃多少。但这里有一个我没料到的。你的服务员的体重。哦，天哪。
Tim During of the University of Gertengen in Germany and Cornell's Brian Wonsink, one of the leading scholars of eating behavior, went to more than 50 restaurants in the US, from chains like Apple, bees, and Olive Garden to smaller independent establishments, and they looked at interactions between diners and servers. They found that customers were four times as likely to order dessert when they were served by wait staff with high body mass indexes Then those with low BMI's Wow
德国格廷根大学的蒂姆·迪林和康奈尔大学的饮食行为顶尖学者之一布莱恩·旺辛克前往美国50多家餐厅，从苹果蜂（Applebee's）和橄榄园（Olive Garden）等连锁店到较小的独立餐厅，他们观察了食客和服务器之间的互动。他们发现，当由身体质量指数（BMI）高的服务人员服务时，顾客点甜点的可能性是BMI低的服务人员服务时的四倍。哇
People also ordered more alcohol from heavy servers than from slimmer ones and the BMI of the diners themselves didn't matter at all Now this is what's called an observational study. It wasn't a controlled experiment It doesn't mean that heavy waiters necessarily cause people to order the apple chimichis cake. Still, it shows once again how quiet factors the setting we're in, the social cues around us can influence what we do and even what we eat.
与身材苗条的服务员相比，人们从较胖的服务员那里点的酒也更多，而食客自身的BMI完全不重要。现在，这被称为观察性研究。这不是对照实验。这并不意味着胖服务员必然导致人们点苹果奇米琪蛋糕。尽管如此，它再次表明了诸如我们所处的环境、我们周围的社会暗示等安静的因素如何能够影响我们的行为甚至我们吃的东西。
Here's a question for you Dan. If I want to avoid this kind of bias, do you think it makes sense for me to decide what I'm going to order before the waiter actually shows up at my table? Absolutely. There's a lot of evidence in eating and even in other kinds of behaviors that when we make better decisions, when we make them in advance, rather than at that moment of truth
这里有个问题要问你，丹。如果我想避免这种偏见，你认为在服务员走到我桌子前之前就决定好我要点什么，这合乎情理吗？绝对的。有很多证据表明，在饮食甚至其他行为中，当我们做出更好的决定时，是在我们提前做出决定，而不是在那个真理的时刻
when the triple brownie explosion melt is staring us in the face. I like that because of course there's all this research showing that we make better decisions for our future cells and so I'm going to tell you right now Dan, I'm going to stick to my next 60 second deadline on my next stop what science segment. Okay well I'm going to set the timer and it's going off right now. Alright this is a study that makes me very happy. If you're in a diet should you allow yourself to cheat? The rational answer is no. The hidden
当三重布朗尼爆炸熔岩蛋糕直勾勾盯着我们的时候。我喜欢这样，因为当然有所有这些研究表明，我们为未来的自己做出更好的决定，所以我现在要告诉你，丹，我将在我的下一个“别管我”科学环节中坚持我下一个60秒的截止日期。好吧，我要设置计时器，它现在就要响了。好吧，这是一项让我非常高兴的研究。如果你在节食，你应该允许自己破戒吗？理性的答案是不。隐秘
brain answer is yes. A study in the Journal of Consumer Psychology finds that when diners are told they can have a day off each week from their diets, when they can eat whatever they want, this is a day of planned cheating. They did just as well when it came to losing weight as diners who didn't give themselves any room to cheat. Even better, the dieters who cheated reported being happier with their diets and maybe would stick to them much longer. The researchers have a wonderful academic euphemism to describe this kind of cheating.
大脑的答案是肯定的。发表在《消费者心理学杂志》上的一项研究发现，当食客被告知他们每周可以有一天从节食中放假，可以吃任何他们想吃的东西时，这就是计划中的破戒日。在减重方面，他们的表现与那些不给自己留任何破戒空间的食客一样好。更好的是，那些破戒的节食者报告说对他们的节食更满意，并且可能会坚持更长时间。研究人员有一个极好的学术委婉语来描述这种破戒。
They call these hedonic deviations. Nice. The important thing to remember here is that the cheating has to be planned and deliberate. Most diets end with a crash, and when you crash, you feel like you failed. When you plan your hedonic deviations, it's not a crash, it's just a control landing before you take off again. It puts you in charge, makes you happier,
他们称之为享乐偏差。不错。这里要记住的重要一点是，破戒必须是有计划的、刻意的。大多数节食都以崩溃告终，而当你崩溃时，你会觉得自己失败了。当你计划你的享乐偏差时，这不是崩溃，这只是在你再次起飞前的一次受控着陆。它让你掌控全局，让你更快乐，
might have long-term health benefits. Yeah, that's quite fascinating. I actually think that some of it also has to do with autonomy. That when you're on a diet you're very controlled. And so if you have this escape valve where you you're in control, just for one day, that can probably make you feel better and probably boost adherence. I also love the idea of the hedonic deviation. I think that I like to consider stopwatch science,
可能会带来长期的健康益处。是的，这非常迷人。我实际上认为其中一些也与自主性有关。当你节食时，你受到严格控制。所以如果你有这个逃生阀，让你掌控局面，哪怕只有一天，这可能会让你感觉更好，并可能提高依从性。我也很喜欢享乐偏差这个想法。我想我愿意把“别管我”科学视为
a hedonic deviation in the lives of American listeners. I tell you what, I think I'm gonna stick to my time better the next time Dan. If occasionally, maybe once every two weeks, you give me two minutes. Okay, we can have a cheat day for stopwatch science. Alright, so there you have it, buy a big table and cut your food into tiny pieces. Be mindful of your eating companions, or, as Dan would put it, eat with men, not women. Eat a big breakfast, not a big dinner, tell kids vegetables are tasty and not very healthy. Have a rule of thumb when you go to a restaurant, one drink, one entre. And if you're going on a diet, plan on indulging yourself once in a
美国听众生活中的一种享乐偏差。我告诉你，下次丹，如果偶尔，也许每两周一次，你给我两分钟，我想我会更好地坚持我的时间。好吧，我们可以为“别管我”科学设立一个作弊日。好吧，这就是全部，买一张大桌子，把你的食物切成小块。注意你一起吃饭的同伴，或者，正如丹所说，和男人一起吃，而不是女人。吃一顿丰盛的早餐，而不是丰盛的晚餐，告诉孩子们蔬菜很美味，而不是很健康。去餐厅时有一个经验法则，一杯饮料，一道主菜。如果你正在节食，计划偶尔纵容自己一下。
while. Danping, thank you for joining me on Stopwatch Science. Always a pleasure, Shrunker. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar-Kalasin, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Find more Hidden Brain on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and hear my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedathan out the new NPR1 app for your phone for conversations you won't hear anywhere else. This week, GuyRaz interviews Ted Curator Chris Anderson where they discuss the secrets to giving a great Ted Talk. Search for Ted Radio on the NPR1 app where you can also find stories from your local station
丹·平克，谢谢你加入我的“别管我”科学节目。非常荣幸，尚卡尔。《隐秘的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔-卡拉辛、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Instagram 上寻找更多《隐秘的大脑》，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，为你的手机下载全新的 NPR1 应用，获取你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话。本周，盖伊·拉兹采访了 TED 策展人克里斯·安德森，他们讨论了发表精彩 TED 演讲的秘密。在 NPR1 应用上搜索 TED Radio，你还可以在那里找到你当地电台的故事
and more great podcasts. NPR-1 is in the app store now. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及更多精彩的播客。NPR-1 现在已在应用商店上架。你当前还没有此剧集的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子以留下评论。